[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 25 octobre
elle est opposé à la privatisation des
rats tara's embarqué voulue par le
gouvernement
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes a lancé sa première
manifestation numérique contre la mesure
plus d'un million trois cent mille
personnes se sont jointes au mouvement
nous en parlons sur ce plateau avec le
président de l'association élite
yvelinois et daniel piron elancourt
accueillait dimanche dernier son tout
premier salon du livre c'était à la
commanderie des templiers et l'événement
a réuni une cinquantaine d'auteurs
locaux et nationaux pour organisée par
les amis du passé d'elancourt nous
étions sur place
enfin un entretien dans ce journal louis
burton est au micro de tv 78 le skipper
originaire de rambouillet sera engagée
dans la treizième transat jacques vabre
course de voile transatlantique reliant
le havre à salvador de bahia au brésil
et par le 5 novembre
on débute ce journal par une visite
celle d' emmanuel macron cet après midi
sur le plateau de saclay le président de
la république s'est rendu dans plusieurs
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et notamment l'école polytechnique ou
centrale supélec où il tient en ce
moment même un discours et déplacement
pour mettre en lumière l'importance de
la constitution d'un pôle d'excellence
autour notamment de l'université paris
saclay créée en 2014 elle regroupe
plusieurs établissements dont
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
objectif devenir à terme une silicon
valley à la française un projet qui a eu
depuis du mal à démarrer première
convention signée hier l' agence
française pour la biodiversité et
l'office national des forêts se sont
unis officiellement dans la forêt de
rambouillet les deux structures souhaite
mener des opérations de reconquête au
niveau des territoires pour développer
la biodiversité est les détails avec ce
sujet de patrick jacques de dixmude et
mie câline hydro préserver développer la
faune et la flore c'est l'objectif de la
convention signée ce mardi 24 octobre
dans la forêt de rambouillet entre le
nfl agence française pour la
biodiversité
toute nouvelle structure créée début
2010 est et qui compte aujourd'hui près
de 1300 agents sur le territoire et donc
mettre en synergie
ce qu'on reste deux établissements
publics indépendants l'un de l'autre
mais travailler ensemble pour mettre en
synergie nos compétences pour en matière
de connaissances d'aller à la rencontre
du public en matière de formation de nos
agents tirer aussi les enseignements
réciproque à bénéfice réciproque si je
puis dire de ce que nous faisons les uns
et les autres basse et démultiplier
l'action
si on imagine pouvoir tout faire tout
seul on passe à côté l'exercice
l'événement a également permis d'exposer
un plan d'aménagement d'une parcelle
forestière dans le domaine de
rambouillet un axe de travail présent
dans les deux structures notamment en
ile de france vous savez que l'un des
grands problèmes de la biodiversité
c'est les ruptures liées parler aux
infrastructures qui coupent qui
découpent les milieux c'est à dire que
c'est pas seulement le fait que la
nature et grèce c'est aussi qu'elle soit
fractionné et qu'elles ne permettent pas
aux animaux espèce de se propager
selon une étude allemande près de 80%
les insectes ont disparu dans les aires
protégées en europe depuis 30 ans et que
la signature de cette convention les
deux structures espère inverser cette
tendance dans les prochaines années sur
le territoire français un invité marc a
rejoint sur ce plateau daniel guerreau
bonsoir oui bonsoir êtes yvelinois mais
vous êtes aussi et c'est pour ça que
vous inviter à le président de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes qui défend bien sûr les
usagers de la route
alors vous mener en ce moment la
première manifestation un numérique de
france contre la privatisation et des
radars embarqués un appel lancé par
l'association depuis à février dernier
un million trois cent mille français
vous ont rejoint dans cette démarche en
transmettant des photographies des
messages de soutien rappelons le
principe
qu'est ce que vous entendez par
manifestation numérique je rappelle déjà
nous sommes le 4 millions de wons liste
porte parole des automobilistes nous
avons donc comme mission de faire savoir
et faire connaître la position de la
très grande majorité des automobilistes
nous n'avons pas vocation à barrer les
routes et à manifester sur les routes
mais la manifestation numérique
justement est là pour monte
et qu'il ya une grande marche
d'automobilistes kirchen cette mesure
quand nous avons quand la ligue
interministérielle à la sécurité
routière a proposé cette mesure ont
annoncé qu'il allait étudier cette
mesure on a eu un nombre d'appels
considérable en janvier dernier pour les
automobilistes quand on parle de
privatiser il ya tout de suite la notion
de chiffre et d'argent donc déjà nos
radars automatiques flash et flash de
plus en plus + 16 % l'année dernière on
a déjà mis une budgétaire de +10 8%
cette année et la sueur nous annonce
encore des des voitures non
identifiables confiée à des sociétés
privées ça veut dire qu'elles ont une
capacité de flash et deux fois la minute
et on a calculé qu on pourrait doubler à
plus de 2 milliards l'argent perçu donc
c'est perçu comme effectivement un impôt
supplémentaire une taxe supplémentaire
et non un instrument sécurité routière
et et pourquoi c'était important de se
faire cette fronde très vite je le
rappelle la mesure du gouvernement a été
annoncé le 8 janvier dernier par le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
bruno le roux ça a été confirmé par le
ministre de l'intérieur actuel gérard
collomb ça c'était en septembre vous
avez lancé vous l'appel à manifestation
dès le mois de février pourquoi pourquoi
c'est important d'aller très basses que
il fallait absolument qu'on réponde à
toutes les sollicitations que nous
avions par nos automobiles par les
automobilistes à grande majorité des
automobilistes
donc pourquoi cette manifestation
numérique parce que finalement c'est une
manifestation qui montre qu'il ya une
forte proportion des automobilistes qui
rejette cette mesure et que on va
pouvoir je dirais
faire une manifestation qui va pas gêner
la circulation qui va pas gêner les
usagers m'étais montré qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'interviews listes qui sont
contre cette mesure
d'ailleurs on a fait un sondage
opinionway qui démontre qu'il n'ya plus
de 72%
c'est 1 72% des français y sont opposés
qui rejette cette mesure laisse
d'ailleurs vous avez un rapport de la
cour des comptes puis un rapport daté du
sénat qui disent que finalement
aujourd'hui on collecte toujours plus
d'argent par les radars automatiques
mais que le nombre de morts 2 belge part
donc ça interroge quand même beaucoup de
gens mais justement le nombre de morts
je prends l'exemple des yvelines a
augmenté depuis cette année du 1er
janvier au 15 octobre
il ya vingt-trois mort envoyées 23 décès
sur les routes des yvelines contre 18
l'an passé on ne pourrait pas imaginer
que cette mesure soit aussi ont fait
avoir la sécurité routière vous ne la
voyez pas créés sans écouter on n'a
cessé d'augmenter non de khadda on n'a
jamais cessé d'améliorer leur efficacité
il faut bien se rendre à l'évidence que
finalement le nombre de morts ne baisse
pas il ya même dans certains cas comme
vous le soleil foldit est d une
augmentation donc il faudrait se poser
les bonnes questions et peut-être pour
d'autres mesures ça vient c'est vrai que
ça va inciter les automobilistes à avoir
peut-être des comportements moins
dangereux c'est comme vous flashez c'est
déjà un aveu d'échec parce que
finalement quand vous avez un radar non
identifié dans la circulation il va pas
empêcher les gens de rouler vite
si vous allez gens qu'il est quelqu'un
qui en comptait que cette vitesse il va
se faire flasher on va pas l'arrêter
donc il va continuer va pour tuer
quelqu'un plus tard donc fait on
s'aperçoit que finalement cette affaire
de radar automatique n'est pas efficace
tant qu'il serait temps peut-être qu'on
prenne d'autres mesures
on a appris beaucoup c'est qu'en 2016 on
a pris 80 une mesure de sécurité
routière en 80 une en une année je vous
le mets au défi de mon site et 5
d'ailleurs la plupart des gens ne savent
même pas quelle mesure on appris par
contre on se rappelle tous du radar on
pense tout sera n'a pas ce que tu plus
ou moins on s'est tous fait prendre un
moment ou à un autre ça marque les
esprits
malheureusement ça ne diminue pas le
nombre de morts et la sarre a augmenté
l'argent perçu mais ça va pas diminuer
le nombre de morts et on imagine
privatisation des radars
les voitures embarquées c'est à dire des
salariés qui vont être payés huit heures
par jour pour flasher les automobilistes
on se dit aussi à une manne financière
pour le gouvernement une fois de plus
c'est ce que vous dénoncez aussi oui
absolument manne financière il s'est
dénoncé d'ailleurs par la cour des
comptes et par senna je me répète mais
surtout l'efficacité on peut la mettre
en doute parce qu'on voit bien qu'on a
multiplié nombreux attaquants n'a
toujours pas les résultats
donc le flash est un aveu d'échec si ça
servait à faire ralentir les gens mais
non puisque la voiture et non
identifiées donc maintenant aujourd'hui
de verdun en plus ce qui existe vous
avez quand même ce panneau qui nous
incitent à ralentir dans les endroits
dangereux mais là il y aura même pas
d'identification possible de la voiture
donc ça vous incite pas à ralentir
finalement vous serez flasher les gens
ont droit déchets vitesse ne seront pas
arrêtés
donc l'effet ne sera pas là mais par
contre l'effet financier sera là lui
alors vous l'avez dit vous êtes la voix
le porte parole des des automobilistes
quels sont aujourd'hui vos moyens
d'action pour essayer de faire reculer
le gouvernement sur sur cette mesure
nous sommes très très présent dans les
médias nous avons pu acquérir au fil des
années cette sollicitation de médiatique
puisque nous sommes l'association
aujourd'hui qui représentant la grande
masse des automobiles à chaque fois
qu'il ya des mesures qui touchent
d'automobilistes ou l'automobile
nous sommes interrogés nous avons aussi
une action au jour le jour auprès des
élus pour faire connaître les positions
nous sommes au conseil national de la
sécurité routière
nous venons de sortir le livre blanc de
la sécurité routière on propose un
certain nombre de mesures intelligentes
que on envoyait aux mystères omise
d'intérieur qui accuse réception qu'on a
envoyé en prison d'un public qui
accusera réception
on peut penser que oci et sert conseil
interministériel à la sécurité routière
de nos membres
peut-être qu'on pourra prendre un
certain nombre de mesures que nous avons
proposées dernière chose la suite de
cette manifestation il faut encore plus
de personnes
oui zelaya personne qui est indiqué sur
notre site que vous avez site internet
et tout le monde doit t les passagers
envoyer sa photo s'affiche actuellement
faîtes entendre votre voix nous faisons
entendre votre voix mais fait de nous
entendre chez nous merci daniel guiraud
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes le président de 40 millions
d'automobilistes et vous pouvez
retrouver
j'ai dit
toutes les actions tous les combats de
l'association sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
ville et l'encours accueillez son tout
premier salon du livre c'était dimanche
dernier un événement organisé par
l'association des amis du passé
d'elancourt c'était à la commanderie des
templiers
un lieu magique pour accueillir des
auteurs passionnés venant des environs
mais aussi de toute la france les arrêts
g nicolas d'ambrus réunir littérature et
patrimoine le temps d'une journée les
amis du passé d'elancourt l'ont fait
dimanche 22 octobre la commanderie des
templiers de la villedieu a accueilli le
premier salon du livre d'elancourt
moelleux
ils étaient une cinquantaine d'exposants
dans ce haut lieu du patrimoine local
l'occasion pour les auteurs de partager
leurs histoires et leurs passions comme
prisca ancien claudette auprès de claude
françois dans les années 70 je suis là
pour partager avec qui veut bien la lire
mon histoire avec claude j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec mon idole
pendant cinq ans les cinq dernières
années j'ai on dit toujours que le
bonheur c'est de réaliser ses rêves
d'enfant eh bien j'ai réalisé mon rêve
d'enfant et monique de son côté a
réalisé un long travail de recherches
auprès des archives de coignières avant
de publier ces ouvrages qui retrace
l'histoire de la vie ces deux livres
j'ai écrit avec bonheur mais je pense
que ça il faut le faire connaître
sur poignet tout le monde le reconnaît
maintenant il faut le faire connaître un
peu ailleurs
j'ai demandé 20 livres de chaque tome
tous mes droits d'auteur les abandonnait
à la mairie bande dessinée biographie
bouquin géopolitique et historique
le choix était large pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs
je trouve ça génial je dirais que
ça se renouvelle un peu plus souvent
pour plein de raisons je tends je pense
que les gens ne puissent pas assez on
est tous sur nos ordinateurs nos enfants
nos petits-enfants je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a besoin
d'être ramenés au devant de la scène en
2016 53% des français ont acheté au
moins un livre un chiffre stable depuis
deux années consécutives
toujours à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt la semaine dernière une
soirée s'y déroulait à l'initiative de
l'association l'arche des arts elle veut
mettre en relation des entreprises
potentielles mécène ou parent avec des
artistes
une centaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour l'occasion à rapprocher
le monde économique à celui de la
culture est essentielle pour le
président de l'association reconnue
d'intérêt général propos recueillis par
mélanie poker en réalité aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle le mécénat est dans les
mains des collectivités locales de
l'état ou des très grandes entreprises
et nous avons pensé dans large des arts
avec nos partenaires qu'il était utile
sinon indispensable de sensibiliser les
petites et moyennes entreprises à
financer le monde de l'art et de la
culture
vune d'écouter la réaction de jean-luc
malet président est délégué de
l'association l'arche des arts
vous connaissez sans doute yakari et
buddy longway de personnage créé par le
dessinateur de bandes dessinées des
ribes
il expose actuellement une rétrospective
à l'hôtel de ville de versailles 50 ans
de création et de voyage dans l'époque
du western l'art si l'artiste suisse qui
était en dédicace ce week end nicolas
landry et mélanie poquet
il y à cary à 48 ans et toujours sans
visage d'enfant au bout du crayon dérive
son créateur le dessinateur suisse était
présent ce week-end pour une séance de
dédicaces j'aime bien les petites indien
j'aime bien les illustrations un livre
avec lequel nous on a appris on a
découvert la bd et mes enfants aussi ont
découvert la bd appris à lire avec avec
les caries voilà c'est une bd
plutôt sympa avec des animaux bon enfant
ça m'a surpris qu'il en ait créé autant
50 ans de dessins une rétrospective de
carrière exposé à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles
yakari est née entre deux strophes
j'étais chez peyo comme j'avais 20 ans
et j'avais du temps parce que peyo était
déjà un homme d'affaires avisé et le
matin
j'étais assez libre de faire ce que je
voulais c'était surtout l'après midi et
la nuit qu'on travaillait sur le
schtroumpfissime je cherchais des
personnages et qu'on n'y avait pas de
petit indien ni dans un cas ni dans
spirou me suis dit ce serait sympa de
faire une histoire avec un petit indien
mais dérive n'est pas seulement l'auteur
des aventures du petit indien le far
west et son amour des chevaux guide ses
coups de crayon ce qui me fascine chez
les indiens plus que le western lui-même
la vie des indiens leur spiritualité
leur perception de la nature et des
animaux va toujours fasciné et je peux
pas j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à
expliquer à valoriser ça à travers la
bande dessinée j'ai rencontré des
indiens qui m'ont dit que c'était très
proche de ce qu'ils vivaient un 40e
album des aventures du petit indien est
en préparation
les secrets de son poney petit tonnerre
continueront à être dévoilé dans
l'ordinaire
[Musique]
allez on prend le large dans ce set 8
journal le rambolitains à louis burton
participe à la 13è transat jacques vabre
départ le 5 novembre prochain
depuis le port du havre direction
salvador de bahia au brésil une aventure
transatlantiques il partagera en jo sur
son imoca bureau vallée avec sa femme
servane escoffier
il vise une place sur le podium
rencontre avec lequel elle les d'euros
je suis avec louis burton le
rambolitains alors louis vous allez
prendre le départ de la transat jacques
vabre dans quelques jours comment vous
sentez-vous tout simplement plus tôt
plutôt stressé là pour le moment c'est
vrai qu' on est à quelques jours d'une
grosse échéance pour nous c'est la
jacques vabre qui a lieu tous les deux
ans qui est une course important c'est
la plus longue et transat on part du
havre et on va au brésil et on a un
nouveau bateau cette année bureau vallée
2 qui est une machine qui est hors norme
qui vient de gagner le vendée globe donc
un peu d'appréhension de savoir comment
ça se passe évidemment
justement comment il est ce bateau alors
vous avez pu le tester
on l'a testé évidemment on s'est
entraîné avec depuis le mois d'avril
donc il fait les mêmes dimensions que le
premier puisque c'était un classe imoca
mais il fait 2 tonnes de moins pour les
mêmes dimensions il a des foils donc
c'est comme des ailes d'avion mais qui
sont sous l'eau qui soulage le bateau
qui le font accélérer il a un marotta
tiff il n'est pas du tout équipés de la
même manière donc voilà on rentre dans
une nouvelle dans une nouvelle ère
du projet est évidemment ça demande pas
mal de temps et de concentration il va
plus vite si je comprends bien il va
beaucoup plus vite
ouais il est arrivé il est arrivé qu'un
jour avant moi ou vendée globe par
exemple sur 90 jours
c'est un bateau qui
va très vite avec beaucoup moins de vent
qui va plus vite en vitesse moyenne du
fait qu'il sorte de l'eau et qui vole en
quelque sorte et
voilà il est par ailleurs beaucoup plus
physique puisque c'est un bateau qui
monte sur ces fameux fun mais qui a
quand même une qui donc il redescend
régulièrement dans les vagues donc ça
tape beaucoup plus c'est plus éprouvant
nerveusement ça fait plus de bruit
voilà bon l'avantagé que ça va beaucoup
plus vite et vous allez réaliser ce
parcours en duo avec votre femme servane
pourquoi avoir choisi servane pour
partir sur cette transat jacques vabre
alors il ya une raison qui est il ya
plusieurs raisons mais il ya une raison
qui est historique
servane et
des unes des championnes françaises les
plus titrés en course au large quand je
les rencontre et en 2010 je lui avais
proposé de faire la jacques vabre 2011
et l'idée était de bénéficier de son
expérience et puis son sa vision
féminine de la course et de
l'utilisation de ces machines
voilà ça s'est pas fait en 2011 ni en
2013 et en 2015 il ya quelques années
pour que ça se mette en place voilà il
fallait quelques années et puis là en
fait partir avec elle sur ce nouveau
bateau
m'a semblé très intéressant puisqu'on
découvre le support ensemble c'est un
bateau qui très fragile qu'à une zone
rouge
plus grande est plus proche que l'ancien
et donc avoir une présence féminine
d'abord ça va permettre d'avoir de
philosophie et de façon de naviguer
différentes
elle va probablement être un peu plus
dans l'anticipation et dans la prudence
est donc
donc peut-être moi mais équilibré dans
mon côté fougueux et mon envie d'être
d'être devant avec ce bateau là donc je
le rappelle servane c'est votre femme
qu'est ce que ça va changer concrètement
sur le bateau ça va être plus compliqué
plus facile peut-être alors il ya il ya
évidemment des écueils dans lesquels il
faut pas tomber on est on est un couple
à terre mais c'est vrai que quand on va
là partir en mer ce sont des courses qui
sont quand même extrêmement dur donc il
faut pas faire de sensibilité
poussez faut vraiment se dire qu'on a un
équipage donc c'est le deal qu'on a fait
et puis ensuite le côté sympa c'est
comme on se connaît très bien on va être
on est on est plus libre de s'exprimer
sur notre façon de voir les choses nos
façons de voir la course les options la
stratégie la météo on n'a pas ce frein
qu'on peut avoir quand on part avec
quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas ou peu c'est
un avantage c'est un avantage c'est une
certitude sinon je ne l'aurais pas je le
ferai pas et ça devrait nous permettre
j'espère
[Musique]
de faire les bons choix et peut-être de
prendre des meilleures décisions que les
autres non
cruciaux quoi vous allez participer au
vendée globe à la dernière édition du
vendée globe
là où participer à la transat jacques
vabre quelle est la différence on le
vendée globe c'est une course en
solitaire un tour du monde là c'est
beaucoup plus rapide
alors le whale la première grosse
différence c'est que le vendée globe se
court en solitaire l'aca secours à deux
donc c'est quand même pas du tout la
même approche
la deuxième grosse différence c'est que
le vendée c'est le tour de la planète ça
dure presque trois mois là c'est une
course avec ces bateaux là qui va durer
une quinzaine de jours donc on est
plutôt dans un format de sprint en plus
comme on est à 2 tout le monde est à 2
sur cette jacques vabre le les bateaux
sont menées à 100% de leur potentiel il
n'ya pas les temps morts qu'on peut
avoir ou les phases un petit peu plus
creuse qu'on peut avoir quand on est en
solitaire c'est un sprint finalement
donc c'est ça c'est une baisse la tête
on a la tête dans le guidon et puis et
puis on fort pendant quinze jours
au niveau de vos objectifs
quels sont vos objectifs le podium si je
comprends bien on rêve de ça
c'est vrai que sur les sur les trois
dernières jacques vabre que auquel j'ai
participé avec bureau vallée
meilleure place à était cinquième donc
il faut absolument là on a un bateau
génial j'aime gagner le vendée qu'il ya
un bateau de toute dernière génération
il faut absolument qu'on fasse mieux que
5e c'est sûr et puis et puis le podium
je pense que c'est à notre portée même
si c'est vrai il ya une concurrence
vraiment élevé sur cette jacques vabre
avec des très bons bateaux mais aussi
des dégâts qui navigue avec leur bateau
qu'on fait le vendée globe qui navigue
depuis longtemps avec leurs bateaux donc
va falloir s'accrocher et puis et
envoyer du lourd
à la question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter louis burton et bas à vous et
à votre coéquipière ça va devoir d
caïpirinha à salvador de bahia en fêtant
un podium on le sait est en tout cas
merci louis burton entretien de michael
et demi d'euros ce sont les vacances en
ce moment pour deux petits chanceux une
nouvelle occasion pour les enfants de
prendre un peu l'air toute l'année
scolaire l'association ville verte fait
découvrir la nature aux plus jeunes
l'été dernier par exemple une journée au
centre d'initiation à la nature à la
celle les bordes étaient au programme
mathilde de 2000 était sur place sait on
encore sangliers sont observées ici dans
la forêt des hauts baignères sur la
trace des animaux les enfants découvrent
la faune et la flore sauvage au centre
d'initiation nature en venant ici au
centre d'initiation nature les enfants
sont plonger complètement dans un
environnement différent
donc ils sont plus à l'école ils sont
plus à la maison ils sont plus en ville
et il se fonde un petit peu dans la
nature dont le but est de leur apprendre
petit à petit à s'imprégner de cette
nature à découvrir un peu de ce qu'elle
a à leur offrir et tous ses petits
secrets
donc ça permet de les replonger un petit
peu dans cet environnement cette nature
de quoi en mettre plein les yeux aux
enfants qui s'aventurent dans la forêt
et qui découvrent des animaux surprenant
à vos souris et vous a de quoi on a vu
des spas 210e du cerf
[Musique]
une activité ludique qui éveille les
sens chez ces petits aventuriers en
herbe qui finissent la journée en
recyclant du papier en première partie
on est partis à la découverte de la
faune sauvage des empreintes des plumes
tout ce qui peut nous laisser penser
qu'ils aient des animaux dans la forêt
qui sont passés par là donc les enfants
et sera trouvée empreinte de serre
empreinte de sangliers on est tombés sur
des plumes
on a trouvé des petits animaux par ci
par là
on a trouvé pas mal de petites choses et
en deuxième partie d'après-midi les
enfants font du papier recyclé c'est à
dire que à base de danse un papier de
bureau et recrée eux mêmes leurs
feuilles de papier qui peuvent ramener
ensuite aux 103 la maison à l'école et à
un séjour nature qui ce vécu tout au
long de l'année dans le gîte d'étape
pour petits et grands est les vacances
sont aussi l'occasion de se ressourcer
et pourquoi pas le faire au travers
d'une balade dans le parc des côtes
montbron cet espace naturel sensible de
25 hectares est situé à jouy en josas
petite pause nature proposée par maxime
le même pour le conseil départemental
des civils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un trésor naturel au coeur d'un vallon
cacher
[Musique]
le parc des côtes montbron à jouy en
josas est le lieu idéal pour s'extraire
du tumulte du quotidien
autrefois propriété de la famille mal
est descendante oberkampf
il est acquis en 2009 par le conseil
départemental des yvelines pour en faire
un espace naturel sensible
25 hectares en chanteurs composé d'un
rue et 2,3 et en bordées de forêts et de
prairies propice à une courte balade
relaxante au cours de laquelle le
promeneur découvrira la richesse
écologique du site avant de refermer ce
journal ils étaient nos invités ce lundi
antonia et richard hildevert ce sont
qualifiés hier pour la finale régionale
de l'émission concours de m6 la
meilleure boulangerie de france à leur
établissement de pâte à pain situé à
jouars-pontchartrain sera en lice
vendredi prochain pour cette finale
ils doivent leur qualification notamment
grâce à une note maximale de 10 sur 10
obtenus en création une première en cinq
saisons démission on suivra bien sûr la
suite de leurs aventures
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal c'est à
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile tablette tv
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]